hey youtubers it's Charlie this is gonna
be my arrow episode 22 video just
careful for spoilers if you haven't seen
it yet there's only one more episode
left this season there's a bunch of
stuff happening this week and next week
so I'll be sure to remind everyone what
the schedule is at the end of the video
because even though the actors are on
break right now a lot of these TV shows
like agents of shield arrow flash all
the writers have started to work on the
next season already so don't be
surprised if you start hearing things in
the next couple of weeks in the artwork
that I have up here on my screen is
actually from the green arrow rebirth
comic that's all dropping in June I'll
explain that at the end of the video too
because it's really big comic book stuff
here we go arrow top 5 WTF and Easter
eggs there are a couple comic book
Easter eggs mostly movie Easter eggs
mostly references to old movies couple
deep cuts especially number 5 WTF
dr. Strangelove bombs dropping
everywhere war games style actually
there was a direct-to-dvd sequel that
also bombs so the reference still holds
I know everybody wondered where mister
terrific had been I don't think that
he's a series regular right now but he
has been named a series regular for
season 5 all that means is that he's
going to be in most of the episodes in
season 5 he'll get his own character arc
main cast members get a lot more love
from the writers so number 4 WTF
Felicity's father the calculator is
still around but they kind of have an
unofficial sequel to Felicity's episode
in season 3 where they they told the
secret origin of Felicity Smoak her
secret goth history in college you may
remember they had some brother eye
things going on in that episode it was a
long time ago but her old boyfriend has
that special software so that's why they
used those special screens just to
visually show how he had hacked into
their systems but it's also a bit of a
wink to the brother eye satellite of the
comics which we actually haven't seen in
a while I think the last big time they
used it in the comics was during Omak
project I didn't really read that
storyline I didn't think it was that
interesting but they actually turned the
Omak project of the comics on the TV
show into Ray Palmer's atom suit I think
the deal with that was that Queen
industries had a weapons division it had
like a government contract it was
developing weapons it was called the
Omak project in the atom coopted that to
make his suit number three she goes
crazy on Noah's Ark so this part of the
episode was actually a pretty big deal
like they try to get as many people out
as possible merlin puts thea on the
crazy pills for a brief period this
whole transition from
second to the third act of the episode
felt like a complete mess the pacing was
totally off I mean it's a big deal but
it feels like they had trouble keeping
up the momentum with the through line of
hope Oliver's trying to instill hope in
all these people he sees everyone that's
drunk the kool-aid they jump back and
forth between the flashbacks so the
whole idea in this is that Oliver is
confronted with all these people that
don't want to have any hope he's trying
to be a beacon of light for everyone
even during Felicity's storyline like
she's trying to be this beacon of hope
even though everything's going to
around her with her family so you get
that with Oliver's dialogue but the
pacing itself just felt completely out
of whack so it just kills the momentum
of the episode but number two WTF things
pick back up once anarchie pops up on
the screen like hey everyone remember me
I'm the one that's gonna blow the
out of this place and kill your wife
damian darhk-- so there are two really
interesting things in this scene here
one Oliver promising to rescue Ruby
Adams and damien darhk's daughter
save my daughter whatever you do and to
the way anarchy refers to Thea as mommy
as he runs away like he whispers goodbye
mommy and then runs off so as a little
confused I laughed a little bit during
the anarchy moment but but I understand
what they're going forward with roof a
Adams like Oliver is forced to be the
hopeful person even though he has all
these enemies around him like look
you're terrible people you've been
fighting me this whole season but
they're taking the all life is precious
Stan's with his character and on the
flip side of that Damian's arc you know
number one WTF is going to bring hell to
Star City wipe it all off the map so
there are a few comic book things going
on here I've talked about the monument
point storyline from the comic books the
Justice Society story they did the big
hole in the ground like there's a giant
crater just like there was in the comic
books but I'm interested to see how
comic book II they get with the finale
because they do comic book things but it
not in the way that the flash does them
where it's like you know surprise here's
the Jay Garrick character that you've
been hoping for this entire season but
it just feels like the twist that arrow
is going to introduce isn't gonna be of
that magnitude so I am expecting a comic
book twist in the finale but let me know
in the comments what do you think that's
going to be some big moment from the
comics that'll make you scream with joy
and you give you a good idea for what
might be happening in season five this
is really true of any TV show there's
like - two big things especially in a
comic book TV show that they do in the
finale they wrap up all
the storylines from this season and give
you a tease for what's gonna be
happening next season so after we get
next week's episode it'll be fun to
speculate on where we think they're
headed in season 5 they've already
started looking for their main
antagonist I don't know if he's gonna be
the main villain it sounds like he is
but I know a little bit more about
what's going on with the flash that I
know about what's going on with arrow
right now even even Supergirl I know a
little bit more about that just because
so much is happening with the transition
to the CW so there's gonna be a lot of
DC Comics stuff happening on TV on the
CW next year it's gonna be a lot of fun
but Green Arrow rebirth the rebirth
comics DC is having a big rebirth event
so all the main characters are getting a
rebirth title where it's not so much a
reboot of their characters is like a
refreshing of creative teams so it's
gonna be a lot of fun usually events
like that in comics even if I'm not
reading the Green Arrow comic normally
it's just like an auto buy just to see
what they're doing like okay this is the
new direction we're taking the character
that is just comic book related stuff
but they'll be flash rebirth
they'll be Green Lantern rebirth they'll
be green arrow rebirth pretty much every
single title that DC has but so far I'm
taking all the new artwork it looks
pretty badass but just to explain the
schedule for the next two weeks so
legends tomorrow night is going to be
the finale like the last episode of
season 1 they've already confirmed
season 2 I don't know how many episodes
I'm assuming the same number of episodes
but then next week or the finales of the
flash and arrow and then in a couple
days separately they're having the CW up
fronts where they do presentations for
advertisers they'll explain a little bit
about what's going on with all the TV
shows in the fall so we'll learn a
little bit about next season from that
too there might be some new footage
dropping so if there is I'll totally do
a video for it but there also there was
a new teaser for the new Star Trek TV
series so I'll be doing a video for that
tomorrow - be sure to subscribe to get
that
surprise surprise though while I was
making this video like literally I had
to stop making the video to go answer
the door something special came in the
mail so here I'm just gonna reach over
here and grab it
oh man what's this this is my 1 million
subscriber button so you guys are so
amazing you are the real superheroes so
thank you so much everyone
I can't high-five you guys all enough so
I'm gonna put this down because my arms
are getting tired it's actually pretty
heavy oh boy
so like I said bunch of finale is
happening so I'll try to keep everybody
updated on Twitter and Facebook and all
that stuff all my videos are coming
while you guys wait for my next video to
post you can click here for my flash
episode from last night and you can
click here to catch up on Game of
Thrones thank you so much for watching
everybody let's high five I'll see you
guys tonight